all right let's hear the latest from Fox
News senior judicial analyst Andrew
Napolitano who very clearly believes
that Donald Trump has committed crimes
in this entire Ukraine fiasco that
Donald Trump has committed impeachable
offenses in this entire thing and Andrew
Napolitano went on with Shep Smith and
he talked about what Trump has done in
the context of the Ukraine phone call
and the Biden family smear investigation
and let's take a look at this and this
is making the fox news audience go
absolutely cuckoo for cocoa puffs the
president admits that on a phone call
with the president of Ukraine he
requested that the president of Ukraine
investigate his 20/20 political rival
Joe Biden is that a crime it is a crime
for the president to solicit aid for his
campaign from a foreign government so
that would be what the vet to which the
president has admitted is in and of
itself a crime yes this is the same
crime for which that trump organization
was investigated by bob muller who
couldn't who decided not to seek an
indictment because there wasn't enough
evidence well no he said he didn't seek
an indictment because he wasn't charged
because of the DOJ rule that said you
can lay it out but you can't charge
that's on on the obstruction whether or
not there was a conspiracy between the
Russians and the Trump campaign he said
there's some evidence but not enough to
indict it's the same crime an agreement
or a solicitation for assistance for an
American campaign regulated by the
Federal Election Commission where you
are seeking the assistance from a
foreign government that's the crime and
then the question of is this impeachable
a little bit later in the interview and
remember this is Fox News folks based on
the specifics of what we know forget
about the phone call forget forget all
of the things about which we have no
knowledge just based on the things that
the president has admitted the
president's admitted that he made a
phone call to the new president of
Ukraine the president has admitted that
he had discussions about investigating
his upcoming 2020 primary 2020
presidential rival based on that in and
of itself how serious is this matter for
the nation in the
was he legally speaking when Bob Muller
made his findings that the obstruction
of justice is an it could be an
impeachable offense that's equivocal
bribery absolutely is an impeachable
offense there's no equivocation why do I
say that because it's stated in the
Constitution the basis for impeachment
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors so understand that the
important part about this is not Oh Fox
News is no longer going to be a
right-wing propaganda outlet they still
are going to be a right-wing propaganda
outlet the upside of all of this is that
the behavior of this particular
Republican president is so outrageous
that it is starting to make Republicans
eat themselves there are some
right-wingers that are starting to turn
on each other because what Donald Trump
is doing is indefensible you have some
Republicans like Mitt Romney Justin
Amash who I guess is not really a
Republican anymore but he was he no
longer is because of Donald Trump I
guess at least partially who just can't
keep pretending that everything is fine
and it's generating some division within
the party and it's a great thing for the
left if we can take advantage of it
there are some rats so to speak who are
jumping ship there are other rats who in
the Scramble are just starting to eat
other rats and in the end it's crazy
that this is the fundamental question of
the time between now and the November of
2020 election what will determine the
2020 election is do Democrats eat
themselves more or less than Republicans
for example arguing about as I told you
yesterday or earlier in the program
rather about the scope of what the Trump
impeachment inquiry should be you are
going to see some Republicans start to
pretend they never even really supported
Donald Trump to begin with you are going
to see other Republicans double down it
will cause chaos hopefully for their
twenty20 re-election campaigns who's
with who on this and the left needs to
instead of doing the same thing the left
needs to take advantage of this
opportunity take advantage over the
internal disagreements that the right is
going to start having and don't do the
same thing don't start arguing about
whether to have an impeachment inquiry
there is an impeachment inquiry that's
it
don't start arguing over issues that
ultimately it they would be Pyrrhic
victories to come ahead on you there are
arguments Democrats can choose to have
where some faction can win the argument
but do so much damage in having the
argument that we end up just helping
Donald Trump get himself reelected in
November of 2020 which still may happen
now as far as Fox News Judge Andrew
Napolitano here what he's doing here is
not controversial okay what Andrew
Napolitano is doing here is he's
ignoring whether someone has an R or a D
after their name and he is doing what
judges are supposed to do he's looking
at the text of statutes the text of what
makes a president impeachable and then
he is applying the law to the actions
that Donald Trump has taken at least the
ones that we know about that haven't
been covered up and then he spits out an
analysis that is merely a calculation of
these are crimes these are Trump's
actions that makes Trump's actions
crimes that makes Trump's actions
impeachable actions and that's it and
the fact that this is so notable that
this is happening it tells us about the
sad state of partisanship that we are
experiencing right now